hello everybody I hope that you have a
nice weekend this is the Bitcoin Sunday
update now it's on Twitter and also on
YouTube
so we're here to analyze next week I
think it's going to be a very complex
week because we have a ton of data
coming in and also earning reports we
have on Tuesday alphabet and Microsoft
on Wednesday we have meta around
Thursday we have Amazon so if any of
those companies have very bad or very
good adding reports that can influence
the SMP and therefore it will influence
Bitcoin but right now we are here in
Bitcoin in the daily time frame and to
me this is the most important thing that
I can see in the chart at the moment and
is that we are at the moment above the
daily 50 EMA which should be a very
strong support but if it breaks below
like it happened here
here you can see it happen here here
here
if it happens again
then we're gonna go lower and we should
be testing this one because is the the
song where there was two previous
sell-offs one here
and one here and it hasn't been tested
or supported so again back below the
50ma and we go to 25 200. it's that
simple if we go through the news
announcements for the next week we have
on Monday nothing really going on but
from Tuesday the party starts we have on
Tuesday consumer confidence this is
basically how the consumer feels about
the economy their job their spendings
about economy in the next few months
um if you notice the previous date I was
104.2 and the forecast for this data is
going to be a hundred for the one
that's basically not different and
that's a problem for the Fed
because we've been seeing how the
consumers
are getting used to high interest rates
and their spending is not stopping they
keep spending money
which fuels inflation so that's going to
be a problem for the FED then we also
have the new home sales data this is
also very important data to see if the
economy is slowing down or not at the
moment the forecast is going to be then
10 000 less homes have been sold in the
previous month which is pretty good we
would like to see also this number going
down to see that the people cannot
really buy houses which is quite sad but
that's what the FED wants they want to
slow down the economy on Wednesday
nothing really going on Thursday we also
have a lot of data we have to advance
GDP that's basically how the economy has
been growing the economy is still
growing you can see that the forecast is
at two percent
this by the way measures quarter so this
is measured in the first quarter of the
year so it's basically telling us that
the previous data this is then the last
quarter of 2022 the economy grew at 2.6
percent another forecasting that the
economy has only grown two percent this
year which is obviously less than the
previous data but this is still quite
High nevertheless we are seeing how the
economy is slowing down a bit and then
on Thursday we also have the employment
claims this is how many people have lost
their jobs and I are claiming for
benefits okay
sadly the FED wants this number to go up
which is basically to cool down the the
labor market and is forecasting the 4
000 more Americans are asking for
unemployment claim benefits and then on
Friday we have the pce which is the
preferred measure of inflation for the
fed and they are forecasting a series of
three percent inflation rise basically
you don't want to see this number going
higher so if it comes higher than zero
to three percent that's bad news if it
comes lower that's good news going back
to the charts I've been talking about
another indexed all the week because it
might be forming two patterns okay
they're here there are two scenarios a w
pattern which would mean that the dollar
is going to go up on bitcoin because
Bitcoin 3 is against the dollar Index
would go down
and then probably reach the 25
000 zone or this might be just a retreat
before continuation okay so that would
look kind of like this
push down retrace continuation if that
happens then Bitcoin should Bounce from
the 50 daily EMA and then we would say
higher prices but the truth is that the
volatile index looks okay for now
because it hasn't broken its previous
low this one what he did here was
sweeping the lows which usually it's a
deviation and it means that when I got
higher but let's see how it develops if
it comes lower and breaks this low then
yes we want to expect the dxy going
lower and then Bitcoin going up but for
now
it hasn't broken the previous low so I
can't be reddish for the dxy at the
moment let's have a look at the
liquidation seat map in high block what
I can see here is that the nearest
liquidity area is a 27 000 and 26 900.
that together is around 35 billion
dollars of course Bitcoin might come
here at the start of the week okay then
if you go to the three months time frame
let's go there quickly we can see that
there is a lot more liquidity to the
downside that's the truth 22 000 is a
very interesting Zone but of course I'm
not going to be calling for that level
yet because we first have this very
strong Zone that's the 25
000 so first let's see if Bitcoin can
break below the 50 daily EMA if it does
then the target will be 25 400 and of
course if it breaks below that area the
next zone is 22 000 and what is very
interesting is that if we go to the six
months time frame
this is my favorite
time frame for the equation heat map
because if you notice here look
let me do this
if you notice here it was so
notifications here boom price was there
liquidation is here price goes there
then they're not forming some equations
here price goes down Sonic editions here
price goes up
again here and now it's showing a lot of
liquidity at the 22 500. but again we
still have to see how the price reacts
to the 25
200. so going back to bitcoin tell me
why we couldn't see something like this
this is obviously an scenario that I'm
going to keep an eye on look at this
potential level view pattern okay
first let down retrace second leg down
and I would say that it should sweep the
lows and maybe go to 27 000 or 26 900 to
hit all those liquidations this would be
Monday's false move if it happens and
then the rest of the week until at least
Wednesday evening or Thursday price
could come higher okay so this is one of
the scenarios that I'm gonna pay
attention to but of course the only way
I'm gonna trade this I'm not gonna place
a long order in this Zone because that
would mean that in the daily time frame
we would be below the 50th EMA so the
only way to play this is if we see a
sweep of the lows of 27
000 26 900 and then in that same day
price bounces and we are well we close
the candle above the 50 EMA that is
currently at 27
270. if that happens then on Tuesday
I'll be looking for longs until
Wednesday New Year session or Thursday
in your session because that's usually
when we see a reversal and this is what
trading is about trading is about making
plans and then execute them no plan no
execution because if you execute
something with no plan then the most
likely is that you're gonna have a bad
trade so I think we have a very
complicated week ahead the previous
Sunday I said that we were going to have
a very good week ahead and we did price
action has been absolutely phenomenal
I've made this week a lot of profit to
be honest and I'm very happy about it
but I think next week is gonna balance
out and I'm probably not gonna be able
to take that many trades but let's see
how it develops okay when there is a lot
of news announcements we also have the
fomc interest rate Edition in 10 days so
markets should be getting a tiny bit
more complex and more tricky there is no
Financial advice but in my case I'm
gonna be very careful with my risk
management my stop losses I think it's
going to be quite a topic week to be
honest with you so that's pretty much
everything guys thank thank you for
watching and I see you soon